her channel my um games are being
reviewed and it's like
really really embarrassing let's just
listen in a little while i get connected
either side here
his first 10 moves are really solid yeah
his first 10 moves are really solid
chat be cool i mean half who's putting
in the
oh damn actually i don't have an updated
zoom link from her
uh i guess i'm gonna have to let her
know our old
zoom link isn't working
need zoom link
hopefully that gets noticed people are
gifting me subs
on her channel but uh
i need to figure out let's see here
need zoom link need
zoom link old one not working
hopefully we'll get this guy i'm sure
we're going to get this all going very
very soon
um let's see here david needs a new zoom
link yes people are telling her it looks
like
okay good so we're going to be back
let's see if she gets the message
okay let's let's let's save both of
these
all right very very good let's see
how this is going to be sent to me i
don't really know
all right well in any case really
appreciate everybody who's been watching
on twitch lately
the twitch channel has actually been
doing really well i you know it's like
everything comes in waves and
honestly there was a period about six
weeks ago where i wasn't thrilled with
the trajectory on
the youtube channel nor the twitch
channel where the streams were only
getting
you know four to six hundred people um
youtube we were only getting eight to
ten thousand new subscribers a month and
it's like
this is an election year you know if
we're not going to grow bigly this year
when are we going to grow um and
then over the last three four weeks it
has just gone
crazy where youtube has exploded twitch
has started growing
on the political streams regularly
getting 2 000 2200 viewers even
youtube has gotten as high as 40 000
live viewers so we're i i feel like
we're on a good trajectory now and the
thing about it is
you just have to take for me in the
political space if we don't grow
hugely during election years when is it
going to happen you know that's the
that that's the unfortunate reality um
okay
got a zoom link so now we're going to
join up
and then we will see where things go
okay all right seems like she's just
taking a break and then we're gonna be
on
so uh yeah and you know i i know that
there's this whole thing about
the sam cedar stuff where sam cedar
fired shots across the bow and we're
like in a
race to get to a million subscribers
it's not
real in the sense that you know we're
nobody's really
mad at anybody else it's just all my my
senses that we just both benefit from
a race to a million um do i watch or
follow the hodge twins no i have no idea
what that is
people like planet money in the chat yep
planet money's a great podcast
what else are people talking about
president praising arizona today yeah i
did a live stream of that
it was a really weird press uh press
briefing to be perfectly frank it didn't
really make any sense
um but in any case it was uh
it was worth covering nonetheless
yeah we're at night hodge twins are the
male equivalent of diamond and silk i
don't have any time for that i'll tell
you you know i'm so busy with the show
and streams that then i just want time
for to to myself to either you know
whether it's
play chess or read or tend to my garden
or whatever i mean i'm just you know i i
just don't know
actually lance from the serfs contacted
me recently and he
knows about a lot of these bad
faith right-wing actors so we're
thinking of doing something soon where
he's going to basically give me the lay
of the land because i don't know a lot
like when i when people call in and say
david did you see what x or y said i i
didn't i just i'm too busy i just don't
uh
oh my camera's a little crooked i just
don't have the time for it because i
i um you know want to do other other
things
i uh yeah i i guess
the name maybe rings a bell hodge twins
i do know diamond and silk although i've
seen you know just a handful of clips
just enough to know that it's completely
wacky
thanks to chris gert for subscribing
with twitch prime also thanks to hexon
hexonx1658
for the subscription and slip it had
subscribed during my earlier stream i
actually had a stream just like 20
minutes ago i went out and watered the
garden in between and then now we are
back
and hoping to improve my uh my chest a
little bit what's
wha i'm gonna have to talk to alexander
about this but unfortunately
since i've started the lessons i'm
playing worse than ever and i think we
need to
think about that a little bit it doesn't
bode particularly well
for pog champs even though i got a big
endorsement from grand master hikaru
earlier in the week paul 12 world has
subscribed with prime and that's great i
appreciate that
um let's see look oh it looks like we're
about to go live
let's see what's going on here i think
we're about to be live
join with audio sorry for the
delay oh hey there you are yeah i'm
using my webcam for video because i'm
guessing you're streaming this as well
oh absolutely well how's it going you've
had a crazy couple of days what are you
covering
yeah i mean every day is crazy these
days there's i mean i
i know that i'm not a professional
streamer like you
and i know that professional streamers
regularly will stream like four
six eight hours a day i'm not used to it
i'm used to i do my 75 minute show and
maybe i'll stream for an hour
so for me it's exhausting i don't know
oh yeah we were actually watching your
commentary on the
axios interview on your uh twitch
channel the other day
oh no way yeah that that went instaviral
that was crazy like it already has
almost a million views i think it's nuts
it already has a million views oh that's
insane congratulations
i don't want to overstate it let me take
a look no no i mean
we watched it as well seven hundred
thousand seven hundred thousand
okay that's honestly still really
impressive congratulations
still good thank you yeah no but it is
and unfortunately like
i don't know what's going on in terms of
chess but like my chest is getting
bad it's i'm getting i feel like i'm
getting worse since i've been taking
lessons with you and hikaru and eric
rosen and levy
i think i'm playing the worst chance in
a world it's our fault and not yours
no i think the problem is i'm hap
i'm uh having trouble taking in and
churning
all of these high level ideas and
um that i think it's it's like we might
be
the lessons maybe are ahead of where i
currently am you know
that's interesting so i actually spent
quite a bit of time
thinking about what would be the most
helpful for you
because it seems like you have a pretty
good understanding of the opening and i
know you did that with levy i've seen
that you've been playing it consistently
we looked over some of your games and it
tends to be either in the middle game
where you kind of go for a wrong plan
and then
it's a very hard idea to find yeah or
just different types of blunders
yes which happens to everyone right
right so it's not unique
to you alone so i was thinking today we
can look over actually
some examples from your games and maybe
make you rethink through the position
since that's already something you had
um we can work on a couple common
endings that are ha
that are likely to happen that are not
too complicated and
i was also thinking of doing a mini
puzzle training session and teaching you
how to set up the settings so that it's
the one that is going to give you the
best results oh that'd be great
um because basically if let's say you
have only like two hours
a week to train for pog champs i'm
pretty sure
working on the puzzles 30 minutes a day
for for
four days a week would be the most
helpful really oh more so than games
even
i i honestly think even more so than
games just because
you already have your openings down
seeing the way you had your thought
process last time you understood a lot
of the main ideas
and what i saw most commonly as the
reason why people were losing in pog
shams were those
one move blunders and this is going to
help you be able to train those patterns
well i uh i'm at your disposal all right
well
uh let's let's work on are you are you
also streaming on on your uh
twitch account yes i am okay cool so
chat if you want to see it from
david's point of view you can as well
he's at twitch.tv
david pakman um so let's start then
with just looking over two of your games
since you know there are incidents that
have already happened when you were
practicing and um
obviously you can look over it with the
chess.com tools and that's helpful as
well but
having a human guide you to what may
have been the most critical
decision is also still helpful at this
point by the way
are is there some drama going on now
with you and either youtube or twitch or
i mean it's like
i i don't know what's going on with the
youtube algorithm but it's like
i keep coming across like there's some
controversy you're involved in and i
don't even like
you know when you don't even know enough
about something to know why it's
controversial that's where i
am but i it seems like there's like
something going on
you know i'm a really controversial
streamer
i stream chess and sometimes i react to
things and other times i lose at games
so you can imagine that i stir up quite
the conversation
but have you haven't like assailed
anyone's character or anything like that
it seems like it's some kind of like uh
i don't know it seems like kind of
inside baseball
um yeah i don't think it was really
started by me there's a little bit of
controversy i mean it's not even
controversy it's
it's just a disagreement and i think
it's being played up
more than it more than it should be
but okay i'm happy to share if you want
to go into that
i mean what's the like brief what's the
brief
explanation of it i guess yeah sure so
um i started streaming in the just
chatting category on twitch
because it really helps discoverability
so on twitch if you're streaming in a
category that doesn't have that much
viewership you basically can't really
get new viewers unless you're bringing
them from other social media platforms
so in just chatting when i'm doing
pretty well in terms of viewership and
it pushes me in the top seven
it helps a lot with new growth and then
on twitch if you're doing two things at
the
same time you can choose the category so
if i'm chatting and playing chess or if
there's chess in the background and i'm
also chatting
with people in my audience i like to
keep it in just chatting
okay and basically um hikaru made a
video where he's talking for like a
minute and a half about how he wishes
that i would stream
in the chess category because he thinks
otherwise there's like viewers missing
from it and it's going to hurt sponsors
whereas every time i've worked with
sponsors they don't actually care about
a category
they sponsor people based on individual
streams
or actual events so like pogchamps one
was a huge success so
pogchamps 2 is going to do well based on
those numbers not on the category
numbers
and my argument is if i can choose a
category i might as well try to go for
the one that's going to get the most
eyeballs
so in other words the controversy is
if you're chatting and playing chess
there's a difference of opinion
about which category is more
advantageous to you
versus to the online chess community at
large
yeah so so hikari basically made the
argument that i'm hurting sponsorship by
staying and just chatting
whereas i said if i'm able to decide i
think getting it to a wider audience
that wouldn't normally watch chess is
actually more helpful
and it also helps me as an individual
streamer for sure i'm also
self-motivated to get higher viewership
wow wow do you think the chess community
will recover
from this from the chess category
i guess from this controversy i don't
think it's actually a controversy
i was honestly surprised to see that
there was a youtube video on it i
thought hikaru was spoofing when he
started
with the clip um which honestly i think
he kind of is meaning to you because he
doesn't say anything really
controversial he's just like
i wish alexander would stream in chess
because it's better for sponsors whereas
i'm
whereas i'm like well if you've ever
talked to sponsors that's actually not
the case
and we can agree to disagree and i
respect hikaru a lot as a person i think
he's done
huge things for chess and if he has a
different opinion that's basically okay
with me
but i think if you're any kind of
content creator or
if you're any kind of business person
you have to think a lot about your
metrics and if you're on a platform that
isn't going to show you to new people
unless you're a little bit smarter with
how you think of it and you're evolving
then that's that's on you and i also
generally don't like
being put on the blame for other people
not getting viewership i think if you're
a content creator it's
like 90 the work you're doing and not
putting the blame on other people
that's been my experience i mean listen
uh
people have to pull themselves up by
their bootstraps as ridiculous as as
that sounds and as
absolutely no sense as it makes um in
the political space
but no i think it's like yeah we we have
to uh
at this point um it seems that people's
success is
mostly determined by what they are doing
in this space
i wouldn't say it's a total meritocracy
i think there are definitely different
things that go on and there's cheap ways
i think to get viewership in different
spaces i don't know what they are in
your space
but certainly like in my space the cheap
way to get viewers
is you you have a political awakening
where you completely change trajectory
and you say i was i was
i didn't see i was blinded before i've
now
seen the light you do it doesn't have to
be a 180 it can be happened slowly
and then the game the game of it is
you don't lose all of your original
viewers but you have this whole new
set of people who are like oh this guy's
enlightened or this gal is enlightened
and now i'm going to follow them and
it's sort of like a play on that you
know that's the cheap way to do it in
myspace
that makes a lot of sense um and i mean
you know
trust is still really new on twitch and
like if the rules change and twitch is
super strict about categories then
obviously
i'll i'll change then as well and i'm
all i'm
generally pretty receptive to feedback
but ever since this has happened
i get like 30 messages an hour about
this just pinging me non-stop
um so it's definitely sent a lot of
people my way since i don't know if it
actually has an impact but it just makes
me feel like well
i've explained my reasoning but
especially on twitch people don't
actually watch the video and they just
come in
and it's live so they kind of miss the
context and they often don't go and
rewatch it
yeah last thing before we move on have
you taken a position
on the david pakman versus sam cedar
race to a million youtube subscribers or
are you abstaining from that
oh i've never heard about this tell me
more well it's
there were shots fired across the bow
yesterday by sam cedar
claiming that i may be using bots to
more rapidly approach a million
subscribers now i wish i knew how to do
that but i don't know how bots
even work but it was a serious serious
allegation
and it's really it stirred up the
progressive media space dramatically
interesting well i haven't even heard
about this so i don't have a take on it
yet
that's good it's actually completely
fake drama in that he's a friend of mine
and we just think that it'll help both
of us
but i feel like the more people that
give a hot take on it the better it is
oh um my hot take
is that if you're botting it would show
in your
engagement levels and it probably isn't
so
there you go i mean this is the same
thing like hikaru and i don't actually
have
beef right it's just a disagreement and
it's mostly people who are just
coming non-stop and talking about it
that
tends to be a little bit annoying so i
got you i got you
all right well good i feel like i i
think i had a cold take though i'm sorry
i
i could have been a little bit more
spicy i'll i'll think about it and send
you
well you don't even know about the
controversy once you get like
you know once you understand it more
deeply you might be enraged one way or
the other
yeah yeah i know exactly i mean it's
it's something that i'll definitely have
a hot take my blood is starting to boil
already
see chess players aren't really good
all right i'm ready now i'm now ready to
now that we i understand your position
on that i'm ready to go
yeah okay sounds good um
it's funny that that's what you've been
seeing about the chess world i i will
say that
i've been seeing that and then
controversy over whether anish giri's
streams are
compelling or not and what's your take
on that
i find that i told hikaru i find them
strangely compelling for a reason i
can't quite put my finger on
okay that's pretty good and he's been
streaming on youtube right
i've only been seeing clips to be honest
so it's like clips of streams
yes on youtube got it yeah
okay hang on i am
boom all right i think i'm setting up
some games from your position uh from
some positions from your game
also i guess last question before we
start
as somebody who covers politics you must
be super excited how much more busy does
it get
before a huge election for you well i
was just telling
my viewers before we connected that this
is like the time where i'm supposed to
have the
biggest growth of my channel and i was
worried six weeks ago because it was
kind of
slower it was growth but it was slower
than i expected
but the last three weeks things have
gone completely crazy so i'm hoping that
this will push all the way through to
the election
and if it does i mean if it does we'll
hit the million subscribers by election
day which is my goal
oh well i i really hope that happens
thank you
it would put you on the right side of
the controversy let's put it that way
on the one million race right exactly i
already gave my cold take so i might as
well be right now
okay hang on i am inviting you
oh cool you saw it already um and do you
see the current position i have
no i'm looking at a board that has the
same player on both sides oh no it's not
it's
little kilia zoldick yeah the names
don't matter but do you do you see
the board now it's blank on my end it's
still blank
yeah it's weird i think it's a mini
glitch
um let me try another way because i
saved i saved your positions too
so from the openings you've seen while i
said uh sorry from the lessons you've
had so far have you felt like they've
been a little bit over your head is
there anything that would be the most
helpful for youth
no they really haven't been over my head
but it's just it's a lot
this a lot of the stuff is memorization
and so
i feel like i can only memorize so much
at a time but nothing's
there was like one end game pattern that
hikaru showed me which even he said was
probably
you know not going to come up or at
least not be super useful but it was
more just the idea
okay makes sense um yeah
end games end games in general can be
really tricky
okay let me try to set it up again
okay um do you see a
do you see i'm checking your screen as
well there's just a little bit delay
now i see two bishops okay you see two
bishops all right maybe it's gonna work
now
yeah sorry i don't know why i see the
pieces sometimes
and whoever i'm doing the analysis board
with doesn't
um do you see it's do you see pieces
moving now
um no it's still blank
hmm okay let's see
it's still blank for you and the
position has been set and you still
it still isn't showing up yeah let me
see if i just refresh
oh uh well now no now i just see a blank
board okay that didn't work
okay do you see anything now
let me see here i've got something at
the bottom of my screen that looks like
what i'm supposed to be at
oh i i think i invited you to the game
and you're not here um
because you left and i had just made you
the owner let me try again
okay um
oops sorry just a second
oh it looks like we're live on chess tv
right now look at that
yeah we are live on chess tv and i'm
here trying to set up the board properly
and trying to fix whatever is going on
with this
it's weird because it usually works for
me and then occasionally i have a bug
here and there
all right you know what i'm just gonna
set a new analysis board and it should
fix it
okay i'll just wait for the invite okay
um
okay i sent you an invite
uh are you right now it looks like
you're in chess.com home not in live
okay sorry i go to live yeah so
chess.com live
okay okay i see the board
but i see no pieces on it
that's really weird um
because i should be able to invite you
to an analysis board
yeah wow you see no pieces at all
and i don't see you as a student on it i
think this is a new board that's why
okay okay now this is fine this is fine
um do you see okay now you now you see
the pieces right i do now i do
okay perfect all right we're almost
there sorry about that
okay and do you see the position
right now with the rook on d6 yes it's
cool so it was just about refreshing i
see a totally different position than
you now
okay
and it looks also reversed from the
standpoint of uh black
and white yeah the the reversal part
should generally be fine yep
okay i think i have an idea of how to
fix this i think if i invite you to
not okay one second if this works i'm
gonna we're gonna fix it for the rest of
the lesson
beautiful
okay
okay um
all right
let me know if you got an invite do you
see the current board
yes i do okay let me reverse now all
right so so that's how to fix it
basically i have to start a clean
analysis board or it's going to mess
things up
okay okay i'll and i'll let chess come
to about that also
all right perfect so um also in the
upper right
corner if you click on the settings bar
and you scroll down there's a little
flip board sign
okay got it okay perfect um
so i wanted to go to this move
move 17 does this game look familiar at
all to you
um well not immediately but i
as we get into it it should okay no
worries
so try to come up with a plan
here um so pretend you're playing this
with the black pieces
and and try to see what you would do
here
uh okay let's see
i guess i think i'd be trying to
to develop the plan on uh the hgf
files because i've got um
some some pawns and i have my bishop and
knight
white's brook king and queen are on this
side and so i think i would start over
on this side
okay so what what kind of moves would
you be looking at here
well i'd be looking maybe first to
unblock the bishop in some way that
would be productive
so maybe getting the knight out of the
way or looking at whether
h5 might be something to do
um what else maybe bringing the knight
over to d7
and then bringing the queen into
g5 maybe would be a possibility
what else would i look at um i
i would maybe think ahead a little bit
and well
the knight over to or the king to h8
doesn't seem to make sense then it'd be
lined up with that white
bishop so it seems there's not an
immediate reason i would think of to do
that
yeah okay so you're thinking through
this position really well
and kind of in a similar way to when you
played it so i actually took this
position from one of your games
and you had the black pieces here and
you played g5
which was a slight inaccuracy mostly
because
when you have a position like this with
the characteristics
that you fianchettoed your bishop on g7
you have a pawn on g6 a pawn on e5
one of the most common themes to try to
break through these positions
is to go for an f7 f5 push
and when you make a move like g5 you
immediately weaken the light squares
and i'm telling you this because any
time you're going to have an opening
like this this is always a plan that
you're going to want to keep an eye out
for especially when the position is
really close and you need to think of a
way through
so the idea would be i bring the knight
either to d7
well i guess i wouldn't want to go to h5
if this is the plan
and then look at playing f5 right um
knight h5 is also honestly a pretty
interesting idea and i think it works
here as well so you can either do knight
h5 or knight d7 knight h5 you're gonna
have to deal with threats of g4 in the
future so you have to play a little bit
more aggressively
knight d7 is a little bit more defensive
so it's more of a stylistic choice here
okay um
but but the point was g5 is a move that
seems so intuitive because you've done
all of the development and now you're
just trying to figure out a way to break
open right
but it's actually a pretty common
mistake in positions like this because
you have to think
with a white queen out and the pawn on
e4 you don't want to let your opponent
control those light squares
okay yeah exactly so um
that's why the correct plan you should
have gone for was something like knight
d7
and let's say that your opponent tries
to come up with a plan here as well
i'm not and let's say your opponent just
plays a move like
bringing the rook out
i i'm trying to think how your opponent
would play but let's just just make a
move like rook d1
okay how would you continue here well i
don't think anything
happened that would prevent me from from
going with my f5 plan
yeah yeah so you can play f5 here and
let's say i take what do you think is
better to take back with
well okay so if i take with the pawn i'm
defending the pawn
with the rook so the queen can't take it
but it could be subject to another
attack maybe
although i don't immediately see what it
would be maybe uh g4
um if i take with the rook i'm
immediately attacking the queen
and then the queen would have to move
where would the queen go
um i guess the queen would maybe go over
to e e4
or no not e4 e3 or e2 i don't know or
maybe line up with my king on the g file
yeah so the queen would have to go back
and then what would the advantage of
having your rook on f5b
uh maybe it would allow me to bring the
queen to g5 and then
start building some kind of attack over
on this side yep
and are there any drawbacks from taking
with the rook
not that i can immediately see so
i think you you have part of this
correctly so rook takes a five you saw
the main point it's attacking the queen
um you do you are going to be able to
play a more aggressive plan
especially with doubling up the rook so
i really like that
the one thing you have to be careful
with let's just say he goes back to
say queenie2 the one drawback is this
the square on e4 so you're giving up one
of these
four central squares and especially if a
knight is able to
get there it can be a very powerful
piece and it is putting you know some
pressure on d6
this doesn't mean that this plan is
wrong you could definitely go for
something like this
um but that is one of the drawbacks in
the plan
and if you do decide to take with the
rook then basically you're going to try
to
develop your queen and bring the rooks
to the open file but you're always going
to have to deal with
the knight being pretty annoying on e4
okay and that makes sense
if you take with the pawn so say with g
takes f5
then you have a very different kind of
plan here
because now the knight can't go to e4
you're controlling the e4 square
but you also notice that now the g file
is a little bit more open do you think
that's a weakness or a strength
in this particular case maybe it's a
strength
because it seems like a possible
attacking idea
right yeah so it could definitely be
both i agree with you
i think this is a strength in this
position
if you're not careful maybe your
opponent can get an attack but it
creates a really clear plan for you and
again this is a plan that you can always
try to keep in mind because
with the version of the sicilian that
you play this plan is always really
common so if you
have been having a hard time finding
plans trying to figure out when to go
for this
f7 f5 push is going to be really helpful
so let's say that i just make some
maybe i'll play a more aggressive move
let's play something like b4 here try to
try to play this from black's point of
view to just get some practice with
how to think of a plan in this kind of
position okay so i mean i guess in the
immediate
my pawn on c5 is attacked i don't really
i'm not immediately worried about it
because i can take back
uh with the d6 pawn or with the knight
if i need to
so i'm not immediately worried about
that i guess i would
look at i would try to think about e4
okay um
because um if the knight were to take i
would take the knight and simultaneously
attack the queen then the queen would
take back but i it seems like i kind of
have the initiative there so that
doesn't seem bad
right so white doesn't want to take on
e4 are there any drawbacks to pushing a
pawn forward
it can't go back it can't go back right
so
the squares that it was defending before
say like f4 or d4
aren't protected anymore right and you
if you have your pawns pushed this
forward from your king you have to be
careful because every time you make a
move
so let's say make a move like e4 i think
it's actually fine in this position
um because you have ideas like 95 but if
you're not
careful you're also opening up the
bishop and say your opponent is really
sneaky and goes for something like queen
g3
and i'll just do a waiting move to show
some possible threats and then all of a
sudden because your king is so exposed
and you open up the position
your opponent has these crazy attacks on
you right
this is just one thing to keep in mind
any time that you've pushed the pawns
by your king side say two squares
okay so maybe e4 is not even though it
was my first idea it's not necessarily
the the best idea
it's it's an idea you'd have to be
careful with and if you don't have a
continuation if it's just a one
move plan i would try to go for
something else okay
i guess i would also look at
f4 to just kind of change the dynamics
of of what
is available but then i'd be worried
about um
as soon as you push upon the squares it
was defending previously
are now free for your enemy so now your
opponent can hop on to e4
which is weird because you feel like
you're grabbing more space on the board
but then when you grab more space you're
also creating more holes
yep so then i would look maybe at
bringing bringing the queen out and
thinking of if there's there's a square
for the queen that would be
good to start you know creating some
pressure making some attack
okay where would you consider i guess i
would look at just
e7 in order to link up the rooks
i would uh probably avoid f6 because
it's on the diagonal with the bishop
and then i would look at g5
okay so between g5 and e7 which one do
you like more
my instinct is g5 my instincts are
terrible so i would probably
then lean towards e7 i actually
think that especially playing against
um players who are relatively new to the
game
a move like queen g5 is super
intimidating
because you're starting to put the queen
on the same row as the king
queen e7 i think was also fine just
connecting the rooks but
queen g5 i like because you can come up
with a plan here
like let's say that i just make a
waiting move rookie one i don't really
know how to play here
how would you continue now that you have
such an active piece here
um well i would think about king to g7
to h7 you mean i'm sorry to h7 yes uh
because then i just kind of am getting
the king
out of the way of all of this activity
and then maybe at some point i want to
put a rook on the g
file and then look at getting the bishop
out of the way in some way that's
advantageous
yeah and i really love this plan because
i think it's the most straightforward
here
and any time you go for this f5 idea
where you take back with the jeep on
you're creating a semi-open file on the
g-file
have you learned what semi-open slash
open files are already
i think open is is both pawns are gone
and semi-open as one of the puns is gone
right so regardless if it's semi or open
you usually want to try to get your
heavy pieces so your rook and your queen
on that semi-open
file so as soon as you create this plan
what i like about it is that
the rest of it kind of falls into place
you know that you're trying to bring
more pieces to
create some kind of attack here okay so
this is this is really good play so far
um let's let's say i'm your opponent and
i'm trying to mix it up a bit so i'll
just take on c5
okay so i guess first i'd ask whether i
need to take back on c5
um if i lose the pawn on d6
and then that pawn is blocked by the
knight for now keep in mind that i just
took one of your pawns
right so i would lose a second pawn yeah
right
um so usually my instinct would be to
take back unless i can find some like
immediate move that white would
have to refute or risk maybe losing
right
um i mean i guess i would again think
about attacking the queen
with e4 now in this position
um i would look at rook to g8
i would actually maybe look at taking
the pawn back with the knight because
maybe that
gives me some better ideas upcoming
like another defender on the e4 square
i really like that what you're doing is
breath first then
depth that is actually super good
protocol for any kind of
chess plan you're seeing the entire
board first so
from these three moves which one seems
the most tempting to you
i think knight to c5 yeah knight to c5
is a really strong move here
because as you mentioned you're
activating your piece
and you're recapturing that pawn right
okay so i mean here for what white
honestly has a really rough position
here
i'm gonna say maybe rook b1 to try to
eventually put pressure on b7
how would you continue your plan here so
now is that actually is that a good move
for white in this position
honestly it's probably one of the better
plans here just because i don't see what
white would try to do other than maybe
try to trade off and go into an endgame
right at least i'm trying to put
pressure on b7 in the future
so i would again think about e4 now that
i have an additional piece defending
um i would look at rook to g8
okay and what else
um i mean i would think about whether
moving the knight
somewhere else might give me some
advantage um
knight to b3 with the threat of a fork
on d2 maybe would be something to think
about
and if you play rook b3 and say
white defends against the fork with
queen e3
yeah um then maybe
f4 and
then maybe say queen d3 with a check
then i would uh take it with my oh no
the knight would be gone from there
right um yeah then maybe uh
knight b3 is what i call a cheapo when
you go for
a move with a threat if your opponent
doesn't see it you're gonna get an
advantage
but if your opponent does see it then it
was a misplay
okay and there are some times when i
think it's worth going for cheapo say
you're
your opponent is in time pressure that
might be a fair shot
but if you're trying to play the best
possible move you can do better than
knight b3 here
okay um yeah i mean i guess then i'd be
thinking about
you know the the f and e pawns whether
there's something there
or maybe even rook to f7
and then bringing the other rook to the
f file or just
rook to g8 yeah these are honestly all
very solid plans
i think e4 now that
when you push the pawn to e4 your
position is much more solid now so even
let's say the squares you're weakening
aren't as weak anymore and
you've basically already positioned your
queen and you're prepping the g file for
an attack
so it's kind of worth it to open up at
this point okay
basically when you're considering a pawn
push it's all about
timing so if you don't have to go for it
right away and you can wait
that might be worth it if you have time
to bring your pieces to their best
squares like you just did
okay or you can go for your other plan
which rook g8 you're continuing to put
pressure
on the g file or rook f7 so basically
all of your plans except for knight b3
here were very solid
okay yeah so
whichever one you want to go for we can
we can try to continue it a bit here
because
i mean i guess i'll i'll i'll play e4
because i think it's
probably what i would end up playing in
the situation if i wasn't talking it
through so
maybe we'll see what what happens okay
cool and i have another instructive move
for you here so i'm playing queen e3
right okay so obviously i can trade
queens
and then um
kind of figure out what's next doesn't
seem super appealing because i feel
like this is a situation where i want to
keep the queen yes
that is that is what's instructive here
if you have the attack
you want to keep the heavies on the
board um so usually the queen and the
rook because it's going to give you your
best chance
for creating a very serious attack and
especially in pogchamps
keeping the attack on when players often
start getting in time pressure around
this point of the game is going to help
you a lot
so then i guess i would look at
defending my queen
with f4 oh beautiful move yes this does
so much
why did you pick f4 well i don't
necessarily know that i want to move my
queen to avoid the trade
so it seems like that would be the one
move to do it
yeah f4 is a very strong move
um first if you push f4 you need to make
sure that you're not losing e4 right
right right right
um and and you can see that it's
protected by the knight yep
the pawn is attacked three times so you
are gonna have to be a little bit
careful here but the fact that your
pawns are so close to your
opponent's king is actually more
important here okay
so let's say i'm just move my queen
back let's say i move queenie two here
okay well f3
might be interesting because the pawn is
pinned right and i'm at
the queen has to move again and then i
guess it's a threat of mate in one right
yes yes so i would
look at that um if i were so what's the
defense i guess
i'm getting really excited by this play
i mean if you play like this during
blockchains
well i don't have this amount of time
during pogchamps i know i know okay so
if i play f3
what is the what is the response from
white um
to avoid eventually okay is it
i don't even know if there's there's
only one response that i think is is
fair to see here would it be queen to f1
yeah so okay the only move here is the
one that basically replies
to both of the threats right so queen f1
is also protecting
g2 here okay and then
you're here you have a fantastic
position you're really attacking but you
have to figure out how to
finish it off here okay
so let's see does knight to d3 do
anything the queen can't take it because
then it's just
it's mate i think right because then i
just i obviously i could take the queen
but it would be even faster to just win
the game
um
if i played that i don't i don't know
that it's a it's sort of a waiting move
in the sense that i'm not really
building the attack immediately
um
bishop to d4 i don't think does
too much for me do i now
move the rook to g8 and then look at
getting the bishop out of the way maybe
i think do i just take the pawn on g2
yeah you have a lot of options here so
um
let's maybe go for them so you suggested
knight d3
bishop e5 rook g8 and f takes g2 so
these were the four moves you considered
usually when you're trying to calculate
as efficiently as possible
you want to look at takes and attacks
first so
something like f takes you two and
knight d3 might be the moves that you
look at first in case they happen to be
winning
okay or at least when you're doing
tactics
um but if you have a limited amount of
time that's a good way to remember it
so if i take on g2 i'm attacking the
queen
but i'm also blocking my queen from
attacking the king so i guess it would
allow the queen
oh i think it traps the queen right so f
takes g2
and white would probably play queen
takes g2 oh and then i
have the trade again right okay so i
think that's not so good
okay um knight to d3
i guess i would expect something like
i mean attacking the knight with either
of the rooks wouldn't do too much
because i'm defending the square with my
pawn
so maybe that's good i mean maybe it's
hard to get the knight away from there
so knight d3 looks almost winning if it
weren't for the e4 pawn
hanging ah okay yeah so as soon as your
knight
moves e4 is hanging because otherwise
you're attacking the rook and you also
have this square
but it doesn't work because of e4
okay um well i guess i would think about
moving the f uh the f rook and doubling
up
there although it seems kind of passive
and like i'm not maybe i could make
things happen more quickly
like rook to f7 and then rook to a8
rook a to f8
so rook a to f8 okay so you basically
have the correct plan
with bringing more pieces into the
attack and i was
trying to not point out this idea but
one thing you always have to be careful
of is
you've already looked through all of the
very aggressive plans for an attack here
f takes g2 knight takes d3 and now you
realize
that in order to win you're gonna have
to bring up backup right so it's a
slightly slower plan
yes if you're gonna go for a slightly
slower plan you also want to make sure
that you're not giving your opponent any
counter play and the one
weakness you have is that pawn on e4
yeah right my queen would be under
attack if i take back with my
knight then the rook comes in and takes
the knight and it probably overall is
not better for me
right i mean honestly you'd probably
still win even with a plan like rook g8
i think it's better
but if you're going for a slow plan ever
in a game just make sure that you're not
giving material because a lot of people
get tunnel vision when they get an
attack and they focus just on what their
plan is instead of what the potential
counter might be
so do i need to look at rook a to e8
yes that sounds like a really great move
here because you're activating your rook
and you're
taking care of this threat as well okay
so rook 88 makes a lot of sense unless
you had calculated some
some kind of like incredible tactic here
then that would have been fine as well
but this is one of those say safer moves
okay um i'm curious what would what
would
an intuitive move for you as white be
here i'm always trying to play
like what i think is most likely
g3 g3 okay let's go for g3 so just
get rid of that threat yeah
okay so maybe now i play rook to g8
rook to g8 okay so so we're doubling up
on on this file
yeah um okay and let's say your opponent
tries to chase away your queen
right um okay so i'd think about
whether i want to move the queen to g4
and you know i guess it's conceivable it
could end up getting stuck somehow
uh or i'd move the queen back
to g6 i mean i think my instinct would
be not to take the queen off the g file
so now that you brought your rook on the
h file
um there's a lot of discovery pins
which are another tactic pattern that i
think will be really helpful to be
familiar with
so let's say for a second um
that you had one second let me see if i
can change it
okay let's say you have this position
what would you play here as black
in this position well a square that
looks kind of interesting would be d2
because it's kind of in the middle of a
whole bunch of different pieces
but it seems like there's a really good
chance that the queen ends up getting
trapped because
i can't move the queen to e3 nor f4
nor back to g5 so i think maybe that
is i'm not thinking clearly i think
there what's the difference without
having a bishop on g7
that as soon as i move the queen the g
the white g pawn is pinned exactly so
how do you take advantage of that
just take the pawn on h4 yeah perfect um
and this my screen just went black that
was weird oh now it's back okay that was
oh no
oh we're back up weird because i
glitched out earlier today also i
thought it was me but it's good to see
other people having a skin issue
um yeah queen takes h4 exactly so
whenever you're attacking your
opponent's king and you bring basically
several heavy pieces i keep calling the
rook and the queen heavy because
they weigh more on the chess board so
it's just kind of colloquial
you can always start to look for pins
like this because they're extremely
dangerous
especially when your king has such
limited space because
actually the white king doesn't have
anywhere to move here right
right um
yeah you know i think this is actually a
really really helpful tactic to finish
out
i know i tweaked the position and i took
a bishop off the board
but honestly this is more educational so
you played here um
black to move here how do you how do you
how do you checkmate your opponent
and feel free to take your time here
i mean is now the time to try to double
up the rooks on the g file
i'll let you think it through here so
i'm trying to think
if i were to do that what would white
play in the
interim i'm not
sure
so what would your point of doubling up
the rooks on the g
file b well then i could
sort of sacrifice a rook on g3 got it
so your idea is to sacrifice a rook on
g3
and if you had another rook backing you
up then you would be
basically checkmating right i think
okay
and are there any other more
immediate variations that are similar
you could try
um i could just move the rook on e8
instead
like maybe you know up and then over up
and over
so basically the similar idea of
doubling up your rooks so either
version of doubling up your rooks okay
so so first i'll say
if you were to double up your rooks in
this position um
well first let's say you wanted to
double up your g rook where would you
put it
uh okay so not on g7 because then it
would be attacked
if the knight moves right so i guess i
would look at
g6 or g5 yeah g6 or g5
um i like both of those ideas so if you
were to play this in a game
i think you would still be doing very
well it's not necessarily about the
right moves but you have a much more
direct
tactic here and it's it's a tactic that
i think once you see it
um you'll you'll see why i'm pushing you
for it
it's not a queen sacrifice is it
i'm i'm gonna try not to teach you any
any queen sacrifices because i get a bad
rep for those
okay i don't want it to spread
is it to bring over a second piece by
bringing my knight to e6
and then up to f4
e6 is gonna drop another oh right what
am i doing then i'm just giving it away
but but but i like the idea of bringing
more pieces that you keep having to the
attack
okay so maybe i would go via d3 over to
f4
honestly that's a pretty solid move as
well i think you're going to oh i i
i'm pretty sure that this is winning
also um
yeah i mean this plan is also winning
sorry we can go through it let's say
i i don't even know i have a terrible
position here
let's say i move my rook up here
okay i guess then over to g to f4
okay um and let's say i take with the
rook
um okay so let's see if i check
on h3
and the king moves i guess the king's
two moves are
h1 and h2 or sacrificing white's queen
which i don't think that
white would do yeah i i think in
in this po in this position you honest
honestly you have a really good attack
here um what would white try to do
if i take with the queen let's how are
you going to finish off here
i guess i take the queen back yep and is
there any
and what if it was black's turn to move
you have queen g2 yeah
and and this is another really common
tactic either a pawn or a bishop on
f3 and a queen on the side and there's
no way for white to defend against this
right yeah so honestly you found a
really good plan here and i think in a
game you would have won this as well so
i like that you thought it out
what you did very well is you had the
entire plan you didn't just say knight
d3 to bring a piece in but you saw that
it had to get to h3
so i i'm gonna give you you know credit
for that one that was okay that was
impressive
um but you did have a tactic that
an idea that you just over you didn't
see here
which was rook takes g3 directly
because you saw it kind of you kept
saying i want to bring another rook to
go for the sacrifice
but i wonder what was holding you back
for going for the sacrifice directly
so if i do that and then pawn takes
and just to make you train because this
is what a good coach should do
um try to figure out the tactic without
making the peace moves because if you're
thinking
in an actual uh game you don't want to
move until you've calculated otherwise
you're sacrificing a piece and you could
be lost
okay so i take what the rook the pawn
takes back
do i immediately take back with the
queen with check
then i guess the only real move would be
to block with the queen which i would
take with the pawn
actually no i would take with the queen
and that's one you
or the king moves to h1
uh-huh and i'll take this queen off for
you so you see
still have the arrows and if the
king moves to h1 um
i guess do i check on h3
no no queen but similar idea where can
you check without giving the queen
um
hold on and the white queen would still
be on f1 here yes
yeah and you can go and if you ever get
lost in your calculations feel free to
start
start from the beginning again yeah okay
so i take with the rook on g3
uh-huh pawn takes pawn takes
uh i take with the queen check
yep king h1 king h1 okay so
if i play a check on g2
then the queen has to take and i take
back with my pawn
right but then you just sacrificed a
rook for
two pawns and that's not great that
doesn't seem good
but you're you're on the right plan so
try to think about how to involve your
oh wait a second
i go back to h4 with check because then
the king has to come back to g1
and then i bring in the other rook
exactly and then
um i mean i guess white can block with
the queen
and i would take with the rook or the
pawn yeah
which one would you take with uh
maybe the pawn well i guess the
if i take with the rook then the king
can always move back to f1
and then i would play queen to h1 yes
you just solved it okay you just got the
checkmate okay we'll put it on the board
now
um oops sorry i i kept setting up the
position
and i had legal moves off uh
okay legal moves only all right here we
go yeah so
so rook takes pawn takes queen takes
king h1 and you found the maneuver which
was basically
activating your rook with checks so it's
all forced basically white always has to
deal with the check thread
and here we go
well that's a nice tactic that you you
found without making the moves
you're going for checkmates in six
already now that took almost as long as
some of these entire tournament games
are going to be that's the only problem
yeah i mean the point is you're never
gonna have to actually calculate
something like this but one
thing that you should always look at is
in a position
where you have an attack and say your
opponent's
king has basically no squares left so
here he can't go to any of these squares
right
right also note that
most of his pieces are far away from the
defense right
so these are just patterns that can
apply to a wide range of positions
because telling you to memorize this end
game would be really
silly but the patterns can obviously
apply
try to calculate the sacrifices
um because often giving up material but
removing your opponent's
defenses can be very useful right
and if you don't see something like that
and you go for the initial idea you had
which i believe you also had a knight on
c5
sorry i don't know where that night went
i mean this was also a very solid idea
bring more pieces into the attack but
those are things you consider
you can consider when you're attacking
you can bring more pieces
you can sacrifice or you can just do
small improvements to not give your
opponent counter play or to prepare the
attack
right but i still think your attacking
intuition was very strong here
yeah i mean i think the challenge is not
blundering a piece when it's a real game
you know
right which is why i looked into
how to set up some some chess puzzles
okay that are specifically designed to
help you train against blundering pieces
okay uh the only thing is i mean we
could do some of those puzzles
i just know that those are also very
helpful to do on your own time
but i would i would love to show you how
to do them because they're super helpful
should i be taking note of how to set
this up um
yeah i mean i i think i can also send
you the notes
okay and and maybe what we can do is um
if you scream can you screen share on
zoom i think you can
i believe so um because if you share
your screen i can tell you where to go
or i can show you instead if that's easy
you know that's
i don't want to reveal the wrong thing
right now it's a little risky for me to
share my screenwriting
i'm so sorry i wouldn't want that to
happen to you uh what what if i share my
screen
okay okay cool um
okay all right
so i think
you can see my screen now
yes i can okay great um and do you want
to share it with your audience too so
that they see where i'm
where i'm showing
let's see the right way to do that hold
on
okay again i don't want you to share
i don't want you to share anything
incorrectly so if it's even a little bit
risky for you to
yeah it's a it's a little risky it's a
little risky then i'm just not gonna do
it and i'll send you the notes after
okay okay that sounds good or you can or
i could just guide you to do it yeah you
could talk me through it yeah
let's talk you through it one second let
me just stop sharing yeah yeah sorry
sorry about that
it's okay um okay so
let's go to um chess.com
puzzle learning and i'll send you the
link in the zoom chat
okay and i'll i'll watch your i'll watch
your stream so that i see where you're
at
um okay
so you you have that open yes okay cool
so let me just go back to that same
same one okay so you're
in actually
sorry it's easier if you go into the
second link i'm sending you okay
okay okay so we're in puzzles rush
and click on training yep
and then instead of rated to learning
okay
and then where it has the rating range
in the upper right corner basically you
want to
set it to hanging piece puzzles and even
when i'm training puzzles i
set the rating range much lower than i
actually need
because to train yourself for the
patterns you basically want to work on
puzzles you can solve in like
20 30 seconds so i switch to hanging
piece
yeah so switch to hanging piece and
change the rating range to like
you can even put it 200 to say
you want to put it at least at least 300
points lower rated than you so if your
rating is about a
a thousand then put it to say 700. okay
so the range is 200 to 700 yeah exactly
wow because you want to train them
quickly
okay you want to start seeing these and
just you see them automatically and then
clicks
and then click start and most of the
puzzles you get should be
training you to see hanging pieces of
course
tactics are very different because they
tell you when you should actually look
for it
but i've found it extremely helpful in
rapid chess just going through these
because you start seeing them much
faster
interesting yeah so this is just take
the queen
yeah so hang on i'm i'm watching your
stream now
uh okay yeah so you seem like you got
that one right and then i think you can
go to the next one right
yep perfect
um okay uh it looks like it's
free night yes and i know they seem
really easy
you can change them higher oh no no i'm
sure i'm gonna i'm sure i'm gonna get
some of these wrong
um okay so take the rook
yep perfect basically this
is to just train your muscle because
doing calculations and doing
patterns is very different right
and i i learned this from my coach as
well who told me basically to do the
same thing
to improve in rapid time controls got it
um okay
uh what is actually going on in this one
i guess
here yeah this one has a lot more pieces
going on
a lot more happening here exactly
okay
perfect yeah you're you're finding the
hanging pieces and the thing is this
will keep you super
sharp and once once you feel like
if if you think you're doing them in
like three seconds or five seconds then
you could raise the difficulty
um and try to aim for
15 to 30 seconds per tactic okay
so so these definitely seem a little too
easy for you
makes me feel like i know what's going
on though which is great
you're finding you're finding these so
quickly right
um no there's some there's some
interesting ones here free queen
okay so and so this would be but the
idea is this is a category of puzzle
that you think would be useful
yeah yeah hanging pieces is definitely
helpful but
another thing you can try to do is you
don't have to check the category so if
you go back to where
um where you did puzzles you can uncheck
hanging piece
and just have all of the puzzles in a
category because
if you don't know the exact category
it's harder to do it
if there's some category that you feel
like you keep mistaking like let's say
you keep getting background checkmated
or you keep getting forked then try to
train those specific puzzles
but otherwise just aim for general
puzzles that you solve in that time
range
okay so the idea would be to tweak the
range so that it's taking about 30
seconds exactly exactly got it
got it for rapid chess what that's going
to do
is it's just going to build up your
pattern recognition which is the most
helpful in the time format you have
if you're playing classical chess which
lasts like four to six hours then you
could start going deep into calculations
but when it's rapid you just basically
want to make sure that you're seeing
these
got it that makes sense yeah and that's
that's a good idea
and it's again you could just keep
tweaking the rating range until that's
the kind of time format you
have and doing even like 20 30 minutes
every other day is super helpful okay
that's great
yeah so in the tournament games
you know my sense is that
like the particularly the openings i'm
preparing
very quickly i'm going to be away from
what i've what i've looked at either
because my opponent
will know what i'm going to be playing
because they'll be monitoring my streams
and or there will just be a wild move
played which will throw me completely
off
so is it reasonable for me to expect
that after a few moves
i'll probably just be thinking through
not memorization but just kind of like
playing the position
using the the you know identifying
what makes sense theoretically that
that's a very accurate take yeah so
i think when you have your specific
pairings
me or hikaru or levy or any one of your
coaches
we can give you some you have so many
coaches david you're in great hands
uh you're in great hands um any any one
of us
coaches can basically
help you out with the opening prep just
to review
so we'll basically say you know your
opponent tends to play these lines so
you can have practice openings
you won't be caught off guard you'll be
familiar with the openings and then
you'll just be playing more in the
middle game and on tactics and on
time management right i feel like my
goal should be
not to fall way behind in the first six
moves and then just play the game
as as a new game from that point forward
yeah but you can even
take i mean if your opponent plays
something crazy in the first six moves
and you have to think about it that's
totally fine i just feel like from your
opening
i mean from what i see you made like
even when you make a small misstep in
the opening
it's not enough for your opponent to
actually take advantage from what i've
seen of your games so
i actually think your openings are very
solid compared to the
you know the playing field wow yeah what
does that say about the field
it just means that a lot of people are
are new to chess i'm talking more like
the rating range
yeah because everybody understands the
basics but like you're not playing with
grand masters which
even like i'm not playing with grand
masters that will take advantage of any
inaccuracy you play
if you misstep a little bit in the
opening it's not a big deal you just
want to make sure that
the rest of the game is more solid okay
that makes sense
yeah um wow well there's uh okay so
puzzles in this uh format is good now
what's your opinion on how many games
how how much
game training should i be doing have you
been analyzing your games after you play
them
yes okay that's perfect um one of the
big things
in training chess is not actually
playing games but
analyzing it you should be analyzing at
least as much as you play
because if you don't know why you're
making mistakes then you're not going to
be able to improve as quickly
right um and
analyzing your games and mixing up your
tactics i think is super helpful
and then with your coaching basically we
can guide you for the openings against
who you're gonna play
and the more complicated mistakes that
you're making
okay that makes sense yeah i mean it's
on it's
happening a little too much that in the
first
i would say eight to ten moves uh-huh
there's like a bad move where i fall you
know according to the engine i'm all of
a sudden like down
three and i don't even know it it's some
of the cr sometimes i'll go back and
analyze and i'm like it was pretty even
here
oh and then it's like no it wasn't it
was not even at all but the my opponent
blundered so badly later that it ended
up being even but like i was way behind
without even
knowing it yeah that's another thing i
think
over relying on engine analysis can get
a little bit confusing
okay because the engines might say that
you blunt
i would look at the engines for big
blunders not slight inaccuracies because
they can be really hard to understand
and it's going to be overwhelming
if you try to learn too much from every
game i think it's hard
there are actually two tips i saw from
your games that i could give you that
i'm not sure if an engine would have
made you look at
oh okay um so i can also show you those
before
then the ending the the lesson today now
when you say
big blunders like if the engine goes
from me plus one to minus three in one
move
that's really bad right yeah exactly so
okay in the analysis tool
tool it's basically the big red arrow
those are the big blunders that you can
kind of be
you can kind of see why you made the
mistake and those will often be the
actual reason you lose
but based on what i've seen in your
games so far the big blunders have
mostly been tactic related
so it's good to look at it so that it
doesn't happen again
because blunders and specific openings
are more common to the variations you
play so like let's say you make a
variation
early in the 10 moves you're more likely
to see that than a random tactic
okay so that's why it's really important
to review your games because those are
the tactics you're more likely to fall
into
but then the pattern training basically
is like well you're likely to see a free
piece or hang a piece at any point in
your game
for you know even until you're like 1500
right
so that's why those are those are the
two things that can help you improve the
fastest
okay that makes sense yeah um
and yeah let me pull up the game that i
was thought i was talking about
okay i think i have it saved um
let me see oh and i just give me one
second i'm gonna run to the bathroom
i'll be right back
okay
wow a lot a lot a lot happening today
guys
and uh i don't i don't know exactly how
well we would say
it's going i mean i'm doing you know
we're i'm doing what i can
but uh i think there's definitely a lot
of work to do and i don't even know
actually when the fir i don't even know
when the first games are the first games
might be two weeks from now it might be
10 days it might be 20 days i don't even
know
looks like some people in my chat are
confident in me looks like people in the
bow tez chat
are not con oh am i running the bow test
stream right now
i think i'm hosting the bow test stream
oh my god this is crazy
i think i'm hosting chess.com right now
all of a sudden
uh wow well i really i want to thank
everybody who got me here
and to this point i think it's an
exciting
time to be alive for sure um 21st of
august the games start okay that's fair
um what is my rated puzzle rating that's
a good question 1297 i guess that's yeah
1297
which is not not great um
can you imagine tuning in to chess stock
like imagine if now someone's like you
should play on chess.com and you see me
on chess.com you're like oh my god what
is happening here oh you're back
it's okay please host the show i was all
i realized all of a sudden if someone
was like had just been recommended
to play chess on chess.com and they had
gone to chess.com in that moment
and i was hosting chess.com tv it can't
have been good
that's pretty funny um okay hang on let
me i
i want i think i may have accidentally
not saved this game over here so i'm
just gonna open it up
it was just one end game trick that i
feel like i should tell you
since i saw it okay um okay
you were playing with the white pieces
is this one it
oh and i will pull it up
have you still been continuing the uh
chess tournaments with your audience
you know i haven't done it's been so
crazy with the political streams
and the chess lessons that i haven't
done one since last month
but at some point we will have some kind
of big invitational
and bring it back and hopefully get like
a thousand players the last one had
seven something so i would love to do it
like a really big one
that's exciting
7 000 people no 700 oh okay okay okay
i would love to do i had get a thousand
i i found the game uh all right and
and this one isn't even that big of a
note of a difference but i just feel
like
you're if you see it with an analysis
board it's not going to be as clear
okay sorry by analysis i mean uh just
the the computer engine at the end
oh when are you when are you playing a
practice game with destiny
i have no idea i didn't know that i was
i know i i i was just joking that
you're talking about stephen kenneth
destiny bonnell the second right yes yes
okay all right
yeah all right i invited you to the
position
um okay it says i'm observing the board
okay
perfect um okay so
do you see the moves being made yeah
should i be looking at this from white
or black's person from white from
white's perspective
so this is the opening you play right
right
um and basically there's just one
small trick that i think will be helpful
to you good because this is where i
played a3 because i had no other ideas
yeah um so usually your opponent instead
of castling
what is the most common move they play
here uh
bishop to g4 bishop to g4 right
so let's say they forget and they're
they're you know they're just a happy
pogchamp participant h3 just got his
feet wet
how do you take advantage h3 to deny
them that play
okay h3 is a solid option i think this
works as well
or f5 or f5 and which one do you like
better
i you know i i would normally play f5
but i got away from it because there
were too many games where f5 was wrong
although it wasn't exactly the situation
i i think that going for f5 in these
positions with
your opponent's bishop stuck on c8
should be really helpful for you because
then they're not going to get to pin
your knight
and this is the plan that you're going
for regardless
okay um i like that you played
a3 because you're not gonna trap your
bishop
but i i really think that this opening
would do very well in pogchamps because
you're gonna get such a fast attack here
if that's what you're going for
and then if i get this position then i
start building the attack
with the g h pawns after castling
yeah that's how i usually see it played
um with h3 and g4 and building a kind of
attack
you can't go you can't castle right away
because of the bishop so you have to
take care of this first
oh that's actually a good question so
i'm frequently and in this position
where i can't castle on the king's side
and i'm unsure what to do and i start
thinking about do i castle queenside or
just not castle at all
yeah that's that's fair i
so i don't play these these openings as
white but i'm pretty sure that you
should castle queenside here just
intuitively because
if you're trying to go for an attack on
the king side that makes a lot more
sense
and even if it's not perfect theory
again you're not going to lose in pog
champs because of theory
okay um i guess there's only one trick
here what happens if he plays
knight g4 and he's trying to go for
something like f2
okay so i actually think that i looked
at this and
is it queen d2 uh no that doesn't make
any sense because then i just lose the
queen if i
try to take on the on the um if the
knight does come to f
f2 um
is it uh wow what what do i do in this
situation that's actually a good
question
yeah this is honestly a trickier line
where i guess
i i think this is fine to play for white
but it's very complicated
honestly maybe your your suggestion of
just playing h3
makes even more sense so you just don't
have to deal with it oh okay that's
interesting
basically you just want to not let your
your opponent get their bishop on g4
right or or we can go into the actual
line here
i i just want to be a little careful to
give you variations that are are
tricky to see over the board because
like imagine you get here and it's super
tactical and you're just
trying to play based on route
memorization
but okay you you already had the idea of
queen e2 so you did see that your
opponent wants to go for knight f2 so
let's say you play a move like queen e2
which is
totally fine here and your opponent
still plays knight f6
i mean maybe just rook to f1 yeah rook
to f1 kick the knight back
uh the knight goes to g4 and just
remember that you have to castle queen
side here yeah yeah
and then would i do that with bishop to
d2 my
it doesn't and now i wouldn't even
really be able to trade the bishops on
e3 anyway because of the knight but
is it bishop to d2 in order to castle
yeah bishop d2 is perfect you want a
castle
and if your opponent is super annoying
with his light on g4 what's another move
you want to have
eventually um h3
yeah h3 and then you're gonna kick out
the knight okay
so this position is already really good
for you because you're gonna castle and
then you have
the attack already coming right right so
this is super dangerous if you get a
position like this it's gonna be very
hard to play against
it's going to be double edged do you
like double-edged positions where you're
both attacking
i mean i i can't say i like it i can't
say i dislike it
i can't say i can identify it yeah
okay well these positions are fine to
play you just have to know that you'll
also be under attack but you'll also
have an attack right so it's fun to play
but they can go either way
and and there's one more move to
consider what about bishop f2
this one's trickier uh
yeah so i mean i'm either sacrificing my
queen or losing castling rights right
right i think i might go king
to well i don't want to block in the
bishop
maybe i go king to d1 yeah king to d1
so don't be too afraid of losing
castling if you
have to um
let's say he just makes a developing
move how how do you
continue here um
h3 yes perfect and actually h3 you're
winning because if he moves knight of
f6 what do you play take the bishop yep
so you just win a full piece
so actually he's forced to play uh let's
say bishop b6
and how do you continue here oh you're
saying if if my opponent
realizes that with h3 they lose a piece
yes oh okay
um
i mean i guess now i move the oh
actually is there is there a rush to
move my bishop now if there's not a good
score
i would consider bishop to d2 i just
don't know that maybe h3 anyway
so if you play h3 now he has knight f2
oh god
so this is the this is the thing i was
saying this is a good line for you but
you just have to be careful to bring
your rook
back and you're still going to have the
same idea where you're kicking out the
knight
and then you're developing the bishop
but your king is a little stuck in the
center
do i i mean it's like a month ago
i would think to attack the queen with
bishop to g5
but then it just seems like f6 and then
i don't know uh bishop g5 is honestly
pr pretty solid here uh
i mean it's not your turn to move but
let's say his he plays bishop d7 bishop
g5 is a great move
because if he retreats then you
developed if he pushes f6 then his
knight is in a really awkward
he can't push f6 because he's pinned
sorry oh okay oh yeah
um no he has to move knight f6 and
and then here your king is kind of stuck
in the center of the board which feels a
little bit uncomfortable but you still
have a very good position
okay basically
you can always pseudo castle which is
moving the king up and bringing the rook
over
and you still have similar good plans
okay but but i i i think maybe i
shouldn't have suggested this i'm sorry
i got excited
at seeing a way you could improve your
opening without
realizing that maybe it's just too
complex to even
bother with so maybe if i'm uncastled in
this position
rather than f5 i go for h3
and then think about f5 yeah i i like
that better than
a3 okay so honestly no need to get into
this
i i hope i at least scared you about
taking care of the
these works yeah yeah yeah so now you'll
always keep those forks in mind
um i think one of the worst things that
coach could do i just did like i over
complicated something that i shouldn't
so i'm really sorry about that it's it's
kind of my
one of my biases with with openings like
this
um but h3 is much better so just just
take care of this and take advantage of
the fact that the bishop's still on c8
okay that makes sense and that's perfect
because if you look at a3 here it
actually wasn't as helpful
yeah no not at all yeah
excellent yeah yeah i'm going to try to
get some more games in where i have
these situations because i feel like i
am now starting to see a lot of these
same patterns with with this opening
which by the way i have a whole other
opening that i'm shadow preparing for
uh oh another white opening yes
yes yes yes um but that's you know well
i mean i can't tell you
you're right the whole point is that
other people like austin's show
right i was i was making sure very nice
job you passed the test
is by the way is austin show in the
tournament yeah yeah he's he's supposed
to be playing
um he seems like a like a sleeper
candidate
he seems like he improves really quickly
we had an
odds match uh where i had some time odds
and he quickly improved so
i don't know and was he cheating
he may have had some assistance okay
okay
in my experience when something seems
too good to be true it usually
is and some of those okay but that's
fair but
so in any case even he may cheat
so i have to be prepared for that right
no he's definitely not cheating in the
actual competition um
i will say he's less experienced than
the other players i think the scariest
player so far is it's hafu
oh my god she's been streaming chess
like 12 hours a day
right that's not something i can that's
not to scare you by the way
now that i don't know if that much is
good or if you there's a certain point
of burnout
there's definitely burnout but i feel
like she's gonna be
so sharp
still though i think your best shot with
limited hours is just working on the
tactics
yep doing your game analysis and then
before you actually play the specific
opponent you'll know if you you have the
white pieces or the black pieces and
then you can just prepare for the
opening there so you don't have to
stress out too much
okay that makes sense that makes a lot
of sense because you can see what your
specific
opponents play and that way you'll feel
much more comfortable
got it so hopefully that's helpful
i'm just trying to think because i know
you're super busy with all of your uh
youtube and um political content that
you might as well get the most bang for
your buck
yeah for sure no i mean obviously being
efficient is good but
um i think i don't want to be surprised
by any kind of training tactic like for
example playing 12-hour if playing 12
hours a day is the way to win then i'd
have to consider it although i wouldn't
be able to do it but i just wonder i
don't know that for me that'd be the
right strategy
right and i mean you can even say like
work on tactics
for a lot more time leading up to the
games
just to be even sharper yeah because
then you're you're
doing intense training and one of the
biggest
factors of whether or not you're going
to win a game in pogchamps
makes sense that makes sense but also
make sure you get practice games with
the time format for blockchains
well you know the funny thing about that
is i was told that the time format is 10
minutes plus five seconds
which is not even one of the standard
formats on chess.com
yeah you have to set up custom games for
those right and then the thing does
someone have to be searching for the
exact same type of game
yes but you'll usually find someone with
that game
or i mean you can set one up with people
of similar level
okay okay yeah i've just been playing 10
minutes and knowing i'd have a little
more time during pogchamps
the best thing is to train the exact
same time format
okay the closer it is the better it'll
be
gotcha okay even if you have to even if
you have to wait for
for a game and if you want to like
practice some training games in that
time format and then we could look over
that specific then i can even give you
more
detailed advice about like here's where
you're spending too much time here's
what i think would help
i think that's a good strategy for the
next one yeah yeah that
that would be great um so then i i guess
we'll wait to do your practice games
there okay yeah yeah that's a good idea
all right well i really appreciate it i
feel like soon i should start
maybe winning a game or two i feel like
my i'm losing more than ever
but i think it's because i'm just
processing all of this material you know
you have some wins in there also yeah
but you know one of them was like
someone bailed another one was like a
horrifying blunder you know they were
like
on another one i think it was like i i
pulled after being way ahead i ended up
with a draw which was like i should have
won the game i don't know
well that's that's part of it i mean the
good thing is that most people are in
the same boat as you
yeah that's fair that's fair all right
well thank you so much i'll be in touch
off stream about you know what's going
on and we'll set up the next one and
we're gonna see uh
my goal is to gain 400 rating points by
friday is that possible
if you're really underrated yes okay and
you do seem underrated really oh that's
great
yeah it seems like if you're playing
faster time formats uh your rapid rating
could maybe be like 1200.
okay that's something it'll depend on
how you're managing your time because
the way you think through these problems
and your positional understanding is
very good i just need to see how you're
like under pressure and if you're
missing
tactics or not oh i'm under pressure i'm
hugely missing tactics but
i'm gonna let my mom know that you think
i might be 1200 i think she'll really
like it oh
yeah please let her know and then yeah
let me know after you have the practice
game and then i could look at at the
games you know
ahead of time and then we can analyze
them on stream and see what specific
stuff you could do to train
okay that sounds like a plan all right
that's awesome okay thanks i'll talk to
you soon
all right david take care okay see ya
wow all right a big big uh big deal
there for sure
and we are gonna continue tracking that
extremely closely
extremely closely okay thanks to
everybody who joined me
thanks to apherin for subscribing with
prime and
cal cobra gifted a subscription to my
channel
to alexandra which is great roshampo
subscribed stackanov also
paul 12 world love it love it love it
love it all right guys it's been a long
day for me i'll see everybody tomorrow
you